The jogan Experience they knew the guys
were [__] each other in prison in the
50s in the 60s everybody knew it but
homosexuality at that time I think was
illegal in America at least in some
way it's sodomy is what was illegal
right but that's what that is so you
could be gay just can't do anything cuz
sodomy is mouth and and butt okay yeah
yeah and then they changed it to same
sex sodomy and States along the way
finally so straight people could do
their mouth and butt thing who was the
last the last guy to get convicted [__]
2003 what last dude who was eating ass
in the
1860s I bet you could figure it out
Alabama no Georgia no Tennessee
California 2003 New York Texas Texas
Texas 2003 guy got arrested for eating
ass
your honor he was eating that girl's ass
I walked in I caught him in the middle
of something against our Lord Missouri
had a law against homosexual conduct ooh
wow we could all get arrested that the
crazy thing about calling it sodomy is
like you're talking about Sodom and
Gomorrah you're talking about a Biblical
thing like that's what's wild about that
term like that's the origin of the term
sodomy so if you're saying that someone
can't do gay stuff you're saying they
can't do gay stuff because the Bible
says that
illegal Lawrence vers Texas is what it's
called wow that's nuts 2003 is a
landmark decision of the UF Supreme
Court in which the Court ruled that
sanctions of criminal punishment for
consensual non adult non-procreative
sexual activity commonly referred to as
sodomy laws are unconstitutional the
court reaffirmed the concept of a right
to privacy that earlier cases had found
the US Constitution provides even though
it is not explicitly explicitly
enumerated it based its ruling on the
notion that personal autonomy Define
one's own relationships and of American
traditions of noninterference with
private sexual decisions between
consenting adults [__] duh imagine it
took till
2003 that is nuts yeah so in
1998 John uh gettis Lawrence Jr an older
white man was arrested along with Tyron
Garner a younger black man at Lawrence's
apartment in Harris County Texas
Garner's former boyfriend had called the
police claiming that there was a man
with a weapon in the apartment what a
[__] move oh man Angry exboyfriend
there he is a [__]
move his old white man ex-boyfriend's
just getting pounded by some Beast you
son of a [__] he's got a gun uh
Garner's former boyfriend had called the
police claiming that there was a man
with a weapon in the apartment Sheriff
Deputy said they found the men engaging
in sexual intercourse oh what the they
imagine imagine you're in the middle of
having some good old but [__] just a
bunch of police revolvers SWAT teamex
[__]
[__] Hold Up Hold stop stop they got
night vision on [__] [__] they
brought a
dog Jesus
Christ Lawrence and Garner were charged
with misdemeanor under Texas anti-sodomy
law imagine they broke into these guys'
house while they were having sex and
they charged him with the anti- sodomy
law both pleaded no contest and received
a
fine assisted by the American Civil
organization Lambda
legal um not to be confused as
Namba North American manboy love
Association you know that's a real thing
yeah yeah crazy yeah um Lawrence and
Garner appealed their sentences through
the Texas court of appeals which ruled
in 2000 sodomy law was unconstitutional
Texas appealed to have the court wow
Texas was like
nope we're appealing that
appeal you ain't butt [__] in my
County son one look at here page 25
right here in the good
book says no butt [__] oh my God you
let one in you let them all in yeah a
man cannot layth with another man oh my
God
yeah what is the the origins of the ter
sodomy can you Google that I'm I'm 99%
sure it comes from Sodom and Gomorrah
yeah but what is it to describe when it
says sodomy like when you say uh like
the biblical description of it yeah bibl
well Sodom and gomorah right so they
they were apparently engaging in all
these awful things and God decided to
Smite them right that's the story do you
remember the story I mean someone tried
to put a bad name on [__] Sodom he
did something something happened and I
think it was
it was like a town right yeah yeah yeah
well what was it Two Towns Sodom and
gomorra yeah they were next to each
other they just both by [__] getting
out of control get getting crazy sounds
like Vegas sound like Vegas it was their
version of Vegas and everybody was like
hey hey hey hey and like what are you
talking about we figured out a way to
[__] not have kids yeah and God's
like uhuh uh uh no not up the butt this
is where it says it right here I guess
this is the addresses uh people as from
Sodom and Gomorrah Associates Sodom with
Shameless sinning and tells Babylon that
it will end like those two
cities so what happened to Sodom and
Gomorrah in the Bible oh that was the
fire and brimstone right can you just
find out what it says I just want to
read the description is it at the top
wasn't that it we have to do Bible study
now wasn't that it at the top yeah we're
doing bible study this this I know this
is a long description and doesn't say
anything that you're looking for um it
definitely isn't going to say anything
about butt [__] in the Bible I know
that
[Laughter]
it's a lot of like inferred this is what
they were talking
about I don't thinku in the Bible it's
just it's just you're talking about
Sin but how does it become specifically
sin like of butt [__] like if you
said someone sodomize someone you would
say they butt [__] right hold on let
me do like Sodom it seems like it's
seems like religion is kind of
penetrated uh uh Society on this one you
know what I mean like in the law because
that's what they
say is against the law right sodomy was
that part of the thing comes from the
sin of sodomy sin of Sodom sin of Sodom
so why is sodomy a sin Jesus joins other
ancient authorities in viewing the sins
of the sodomites as the abuse of
strangers neglecting the poor and the
needy and the stigmatizing of Outsiders
whoa wait a minute now it gets weird
yeah now it gets weird cuz GE I like
what Jesus is saying so Jesus is saying
when you commit sodomy the sin is the
abuse of strangers neglecting the poor
and the needy and then stigmatizing of
Outsiders and then Texas is like yeah
butt [__] yeah basically butt [__]
that shit's illegal man don't be butt
[__] no no no and Jesus is like
that's not what I said right Jesus is
like no no no no no no I'm saying don't
be shitty to strangers go scroll back
down so I can read that again don't
neglect the poor and the needy and don't
stigmatize others see this is how we
prevent Wars you other people right
Jesus is saying don't do that and
everybody's like yeah no butt [__]
Jesus said it it's right here hey no
stigmatizing around here but imagine if
that's what the sins of Sodom and
gamorra were they were just shitty to
people yeah and Jesus is like don't be
shitty to people and then someone's like
I heard they were butt [__] too
that's even worse that's even worse
there was probably some dude who really
wanted a butt [__] but he's so angry
couldn't butt [__] nobody gets to butt
[__] right cuz that's a lot of it like
when you find people that are like vly
anti-gay you're always like hm how long
before they catch you in a wet
suit dildo up your ass addition to this
okay um unnatural sexual relations such
as those Customs imputed to the
inhabitants of biblical Sodom especially
between men but also with breasts from
Beasts oh excuse me
from beast from old French sodomy uh
compare late
latinum anal sex literally the sins of
Sodom from the Latin Sodoma in Middle
English also sin
sodomite